cinéma avec le film la ligne rouge qui
vient d'obtenir l'ours d'or du 49ème
festival de berlin la ligne rouge sera
sur les écrans français dès mercredi
c'est un film sur la guerre dans le
pacifique mais donc c'est un peu facile
à dire sur la force de ce long métrage
proposé par le réalisateur terrence
malick de lui on a aimé les moissons du
ciel de lui on apprécie aussi sa
discrétion au point qu'ils n'étaient qu
il était presque cachée lors des
cérémonies berlinoise explications
pascal deschamps presque cachée dans un
coin de la scène l'un des réalisateurs
les plus secrets du cinéma américain a
surpris tout le monde en apparaissant à
berlin car terrence malick dont c'est la
seule photo existante fui la foule tant
ils estiment que la personnalité du
réalisateur importe peu seul compte 9
hrs avec tous les enfants puissent faire
la guerre ou encore et toujours et des
soldats piétons comme les mouches à
l'assaut d'une auteur emblématique mais
il ne faudrait pas croire pour autant
que la ligne rouge est un film de guerre
comme les autres où un soldat ryan
transposé dans le pacifique soldat ryan
est un film entièrement la motivation
est entièrement différente event
spielberg a fait son film pour honorer
la victoire il le dit lui même noir sur
blanc
j'ai fait mon film parce qu'on a gagné
terrence malick a fait un film pour
s'interroger
philosophiquement sur le fait que les
hommes s'entretuent depuis toujours
ah bah je pense que steven spielberg lui
ne se moque pas du tout du fait que son
soldat ryan rapporte de l'argent sous et
des récompenses terre et malik s'en
moque
la ligne rouge s'inspire lui aussi d'un
débarquement historique la sanglante
bataille pour la prise de l'île de
guadalcanal qui devait permettre aux
américains de contrôle et le pacifique
mais à partir de ses faits d'armes
terrence malick réalisent une fresque de
trois heures personnel et mystique
une interrogation superbe sur l'homme et
la guerre
j'ai tué un homme c'est le pire de tous
les crimes
c'est pas fini et ce n'est pas
l'histoire d'un homme isolé qui plante
son couteau dans le ventre d'un autre ce
n'est pas au mas micic c'est un film qui
parle de l'humanité des oiseaux et des
arbres j'ai tout cela que malika filmé
et plus encore peut-être qu'il ya une
âme comme une à tous les arts on en fait
tous partie
ces visages semaine
comment tu te la guerre de manic rejoint
celle de réalisateur visionnaire qui de
coppola à kubrick ne voulait pas
seulement réalisé des prouesses
techniques mais une ode à l'humanité